[Musique]
e
enfin dans l'ouest canadien dont je
parle beaucoup de pétrole de pipeline
mais avec mon collègue frédéric lasserre
on a changé de continent pour rien
arriver en océanie l'océanic est une
région du monde qu'on couvre port en
fait parce que oui il est frais
récemment l'australie mais selon ce
n'est pas une région qu'on connaît
beaucoup pourtant il ya plein
d'histoires intéressantes à raconter
puis l'australie comme la nouvelle
zélande où on va aller ensuite ce sont
deux pays qui ressemble beaucoup au
canada on a des systèmes politiques
similaires la même rennes en australie
par exemple 25 millions d'habitants un
peu moins que le canada sur un immense
territoire
est-ce quelque chose qu'on peut
apprendre de ces deux piles des
initiatives inspirante comprennent thé
chez nous au canada
bref c'est tout ça qu'on va explorer
dans les prochaines semaines sur le
terrain suivez nous
[Musique]